der
Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Moin Michael, 50 Trillionen. Warum sind so viele Leute da?
WTF, so viele Leute sind im Start.
Tains ist auch da, Patrick ist auch da, Finn ist da, Renax ist am Start.
Der Stream geht nicht lang, der Titel ist Programm.
Also ich hab Mittagessen bestellt auf 13.15 und die sind meistens ein bisschen später.
Aber spätestens 13.30 bin ich wieder weg wegen Mittagessen.
Ich bin weg, sobald es Mittagessen kommt.
Aber in der Zwischenzeit wollte ich gerade ein paar Sachen einkaufen, ich hab einfach Stream angemacht.
Was es zu Mittagessen gibt, es gibt ein Burger Menü und zwar ein Double Crunchy Chicken Burger mit Krautsalat.
Exzellent.
Kein Photoshop Bild, Leute, kein Photoshop, legit, legit Fotografie hier bei AliExpress, eindeutig.
Und wir wissen, was wir nicht zu Facemask fashion, alles klar, AliExpress.
Wir machen das Ganze, wir machen das Ganze mal in der VM auf.
Wir müssen ja nicht unnötig Cookies verteilen hier irgendwo, ne?
Wie geht's der Nase? Oh, ich hab einen blauen Fleck, aber ansonsten geht's.
Ich hab richtig einen blauen Fleck an der Seite, ich wusste gar nicht, dass man an der Nase einen blauen Fleck haben kann.
Aber es ist möglich, weiß ich jetzt.
Hier, Banggood, Exzellent-Seite.
Was ist denn hier los? Wir kaufen jetzt ein paar Sachen ein.
Das Bestellen mach ich nicht im Stream, weil dann ist ja Adress League angesagt. Wir gucken mal gerade, ob es irgendwelche neuen China-Geschichten gibt.
Aber hauptsächlich will ich ein paar Sachen bestellen, wo ich schon weiß, was ich mir bestellen will.
Und mal gucken, was es da am besten gibt.
Ja Leute, ich hab's gestern geschafft hier, ich zeig's euch mal Twitter.
Ich natürlich erst mal Twitter, ne? Guck mal hier.
Ich hab gestern echt gedacht, ich hätte mir die Nase gebrochen.
Ich hab mit der Katz auf der Erde gesessen im Flur.
Die hat da ihr Trockenfutterzeug stehen.
Und da war sie der Meinung, sie muss sich daneben stellen und machen.
So lag die Motto, arme Katze, keiner kümmert sich um mich.
Es wackelt nichts, ich kann atmen und es ist auch nichts großartig dick, außer, dass ich einen fetten blauen Fleck an der Seite hab.
Da hab ich mich Zura auf die Erde gesetzt und hab sie ein bisschen gestreichelt.
Und irgendwann hat sie keinen Bock mehr gehabt und dann bin ich aufgestanden.
Beim Aufstehen, ich hab quasi direkt dort auf der Erde gesessen mit der Katz, wo die Treppe hochgeht.
Und dann bin ich aufgestanden, zu schnell hab ich meinen Kopf nach links gedreht.
Da bin ich voll an die Kante vom Treppengeländer geklatscht.
Monka Nos.
Alter, was geht das mit der Musik ab?
Die übertreiben es aber jetzt voll.
So, und das Blöde war, es hat halt richtig geknackst.
Ich hab dagegen gesagt, so wie das ist, du siehst ja dann erstmal nix.
Du siehst ja dann erstmal nix und es hat voll geknackst und ich hab gesagt, oh Scheiße.
Und eigentlich hab ich damit gerechnet, ich hab da ungefähr 20 Sekunden da gesessen.
Du siehst erstmal nix, wenn dir die Nase voll dagegen rennt.
Ich hab erst 2 Sekunden da gesessen, 20 Sekunden da gesessen, so Augen zu.
Und ich hab eigentlich gewartet, dass jeden Moment mir die Nase anfängt zu bluten oder sowas.
Hat aber nicht, hat aber nicht.
Es hat auch gar nicht so sehr wehgetan irgendwie.
Es hat aber nur geknackst.
So, und das erste, was ich natürlich gemacht hab danach, ist erstmal twittern.
Ist ja klar, ne?
Also, ich finde, das ist die logische Handlung, nachdem man sich die Nase fast gebrochen hat 2020.
Erstmal auf Twitter gehen und schreiben, dass man sich fast die Nase gebrochen hat.
So, zumindest danach bin ich erstmal vor den Spiegel gegangen, hab mal geguckt und irgendwie sah alles okay aus.
Hat nix gewackelt, hat irgendwie nix großartig wehgetan und so, alles okay.
Und danach hab ich ein bisschen Kühlpackung drauf gemacht.
Aber wie gesagt, vorher erstmal schön getwittert.
Wichtig, ganz wichtig.
Also, wenn ihr euch irgendwie verletzt, denkt dran erstmal auf Twitter gehen und twittern darüber, bevor man das behandelt.
Und das hat dann gar nicht so großartig wehgetan.
Ich hab schon gedacht, boah, das ist aber ungewöhnlich, dass das gar nix ist, ne?
Also, es war im Prinzip wie als wär nix gewesen im Endeffekt.
Aber ich hab dann so im Laufe der Nacht gemerkt, dass es doch anfängt wehzutun.
Und als ich heute Morgen geguckt hab, hab ich jetzt einen blauen Fleck.
Okay, gibt Schlimmeres.
Instagram Story, genau.
Und was ich heute gemerkt hab, ich war vorhin beim Aldi einkaufen und ich ziehe ja nur im Aldi meinen Mundschutz an.
Und davor, wenn ich über den Parkplatz laufe und so, und so viele Leute am Start sind, da zieh ich immer so, zieh ich mein T-Shirt immer so für die Nase drüber.
Alter, ich brauch euer Corona Zeug nicht.
Und das tut weh.
Das T-Shirt über den Nase ziehen tut weh.
Das ist keine so gute Idee.
Naja, gut.
Also es scheint nix Schlimmes zu sein, einfach nur blauen Fleck.
Ich kann auch halbwegs atmen durch die Nase und ja.
Beide Handgelenke, das ist schlecht.
Das ist echt Fields Batman.
Also das Heftigste, was ich mal geschafft hab, wo ich mir aber auch nicht die Nase gebrochen hab, aber wo ich echt gedacht hab, mir ist ein LKW ins Gesicht gefahren,
war in der Grundschule, so Sachen merkt man sich, auch wenn es ewig her ist, der Grundschule.
Und oft in der Grundschule hatten wir im Hof, der Hof war relativ groß und das war wie so ein Kurs aufgebaut, wo man Fahrradfahren üben konnte.
Die Leute in der Grundschule lernen halt auch mal Fahrradfahren und wie man sich ein bisschen an so grundsätzlichen Verkehrsregeln hält und sowas.
Und die hatten dort auf dem Schulhof überall so Metalldinger am Boden, wo man Schilder reinstellen konnte, um halt Verkehrsschilder zu simulieren.
Und ich hab's mal geschafft, dass ich irgendwie mit Leuten da rumgerannt bin und bin aufs Maul geflogen und ich bin direkt beim Fallen gegen so einen Metallständer fürs Schild gefallen.
Voll mit der Nase dagegen, da hab ich echt gedacht, als wäre der LKW immer mich drüber gefahren.
Und da hat auch irgendwie, keine Ahnung, drei Tage lang die Nase geblutet danach.
Bei jeder Bewegung, die hat erstmal irgendwie da eine halbe Stunde geblutet und dann bei jeder Bewegung, die zu schnell war, die nächsten Tage auch direkt wieder.
Also das war echt das größte in your face, was ich je gekriegt hab.
Ich glaube, das ist schlimmer, als wenn dir einer volle Kanne ins Gesicht schlägt quasi.
Das ist mit, also quasi im voller Geschwindigkeit, im Fallen, quasi im Runterfliegen beim Fallen gegen Metallpfosten mit der Nase.
Also das ist wirklich, also volle Kanne.
Das war aber so das Schlimmste, was ich bisher hatte, wo ich mir irgendwie was getan hat.
Ich hatte in meinem Leben noch nie was gebrochen, obwohl ich früher total viel rumgeklettert bin, rum Zeug gemacht hab.
Nie was gebrochen, nie was Schlimmeres gehabt.
Ähm, außer Verletzungen, von blauen Flecken bis schürf Wunden und sowas, was jede Kinder hatten.
Aber ich hab mir nie was gebrochen, zum Glück.
Deswegen keine Facecam, exellent, du hast es erkannt.
Chrome Tabgruppen sind da, ok.
Das sind die doch vorher auch schon gewesen, guck.
Man kann auch hier schon Tabs kopieren.
Oder ist da mit was anderes gemeint?
Heißt das ich muss, heißt das ich muss mal, ähm, mein Chromium updaten?
Oh, muss ich tatsächlich.
Aber 83, guck mal, ich bin fast aktuell.
Nur ein paar Patches, äh, muss ich nicht.
So, also Leute, ich wollte ja eigentlich was einkaufen.
Wie gesagt, ich hab nicht allzu viel Zeit.
Und zwar das erste, was ich mir, was ich aufgeschrieben hab, bevor wir ein bisschen rumgucken.
Eine Sache, die ich mir wirklich kaufen muss, sind neue Schuhe für den Sommer.
Meine sind schon ziemlich kaputt.
Und ich hab jetzt die letzten Jahre immer hier was gekauft, weil, ähm,
ich würde mir auch theoretisch jede andere Marke kaufen.
Mir sind Marken eigentlich, was das angeht, ziemlich wurscht.
Warum ich die immer kaufe ist, ähm, weil es die extra breit gibt.
Schuhe bei AliExpress, ist klar.
Extra breite Schuhe.
Also die hier.
Nee, nicht extra breit, nur weit, weite Schuhe.
Kaufbar Taobao.
Ähm, das ist auch Chinakram.
Aber Taobao ist doch das, ist doch das AliExpress in China intern nur, oder?
Guck doch hier.
Designer Schuhe für Herrn, boah, das ist aber ganz schön.
Also gibt's die auch extra weit, gibt's die auch extra weit?
What the fuck?
Ihh, all das sieht aus, als bin ich in irgendeinem türkischen Tee, Teehaus oder so.
Was ist das denn?
Oh Gott, sieht das hässlich aus, Alter.
520 Euro?
What the fuck?
Sind die noch bei Drost oder was?
Wahrscheinlich in, in, in Bangladesh Kinderarbeit hergestellt oder sowas.
Was auch immer, also ich brauch extra weit und ich brauch Schuhgröße 44.
Meine Füße sind irgendwie kleiner geworden, dafür sind sie breiter geworden die letzten Jahre, Alter.
Früher hab ich immer 46 gekauft, 46 gibt's gar nicht.
Früher hab ich immer 46 normal gekauft und mittlerweile kaufe ich nur 44, da passe ich exakt rein, die Füße wachsen auch nicht mehr.
Und aber weit, ja, platt gelaufen.
Ist echt so, der, ähm, wer war das?
Ich glaub der, ich glaub der Typ, wo man, wo man zur Musterung hingehen muss, wenn man, also Verdienst gibt's ja nicht mehr, ja.
Ähm, da musst du ins Krankenhaus gehen und dich untersuchen lassen.
Und der hätte auch gemeint, Alter, ich hätte voll die platten Füße.
Und das ist schon, keine Ahnung, 15 Jahre her oder so.
Und das ist immer, und irgendwann ist es jetzt kürzer geworden, dafür breiter.
So, was haben wir denn hier schon, ist 44, sei es weit.
Fresh Form Hero, okay, das sieht vielleicht bis hin.
Wir können auch extra weit, nee, extra weit brauch ich, nicht weit, extra weit, ex, exzellent.
Extra weit brauch ich.
So, was haben wir denn hier zu bieten?
Okay, die sehen alle mega abgedreht aus.
Äh, so ähnliche hab ich schon, aber die sind eher für den Winter, die sind nicht wirklich, falls das die sind, die ich...
Ja, die sind für den Sommer nix.
Für den Sommer eher sowas hier, oder, oder sowas hier.
Das sieht, das sieht ja aus wie ne Schaukel, äh.
Also ich brauch so ein Ding, womit man gut laufen kann und, äh, die man aber auch den ganzen Tag anhaben kann.
Nee, Sandalen mag ich nicht.
Ja, die Nase ist ganz, ich hab nur nen blauen Fleck.
Oh, die Seite ist ja exzellent schnell hier.
Exzellent.
High Performance Website, wie es aussieht.
Die ist ja richtig, richtig, wahnsinnig schnell.
So, was gibt's denn hier? Grau, grau, was haben wir sonst noch zu bieten?
Silver and white.
Ah, die gibt's nicht extra white, was gibt's denn extra white?
Extra white, ah extra, extra white, gibt's denn nur die hier, hä?
Extra white, extra white.
Moment, es gibt nur die grauen extra white?
Ich bleib nur die grauen, was anderes kann ich mir nicht kaufen.
What the fuck ist das, Alter?
Schuhe mit Zehen dran, nicht schlecht.
So, also das, und dann gab's ansonsten zur Auswahl nur noch das Ding.
Das war's, white.
Aber die gibt's, nee, die gibt's auch nur im, okay, das ist nicht unbedingt meine Farbe.
Das geht schon eher.
Ja, ich glaub, das Ding kann man besser auf die Arbeit anziehen.
Das sieht irgendwie ein bisschen neutraler aus.
Ja.
Warum ist da Kram eigentlich so teuer? 200 Euro, sind die noch bei Trost, ey?
Warum ist das, warum kostet das so viel?
Okay, zwei hier immer mal, ganz schön teuer.
Excellent.
Gut.
Da hätten wir schon das Wichtigste, hätten wir schon mal erledigt.
Ein paar neue Schuhe, die Seite ist wirklich high performance.
Made in USA, Kokona Schuhe.
Na dann, guck mal, also wenn die nicht Erfahrungen haben mit extra, extra breit und extra stabil, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Das meiste, was ich zum Anziehen hab, ist tatsächlich, nee, nicht schwarz-weiß, aber...
Also ich hab ganz gern Hemden mit ein bisschen rot.
Aber ansonsten, Heldchengrenzen.
Wie gesagt, ich bin auch gleich weg.
Oh, der Krieger hat mich gehorstet, Dankeschön, huge poggers.
Nice, danke.
Aber wie gesagt, Leute, ich bin nicht lang da.
Ich muss nämlich mal in Discord, da hat einer letztens...
Oh, ich kann Discord nicht aufmachen, vielleicht lande ich im Weep-Channel.
Okay, eine Runde Schuhe, perfekt.
Und jetzt müssen wir noch ein bisschen Amazon Zeug bestellen, Technik-Kram.
Und ich muss immer drauf hören, ob die Klingel klingelt fürs Mittagessen.
Leute, wenn ihr eine Klingel hört, sagt Bescheid.
Und ich weiß, wenn der Chat schreibt, es klingelt, dann muss ich nicht rausgehen, weil ich werde vom Chat immer gebated, was das angeht.
Und außerdem brauche ich eure Hilfe gar nicht, Chat.
Weil ich habe jetzt eine Kamera am Hoftor und ich habe meine Notification für die Klingel.
Das heißt, ich habe auf dem zweiten Monitor einfach die Kamera auf.
Was kaufst du ein?
Schuhe und Technik-Krams.
Ich wollte eigentlich nicht im Stream einkaufen, aber ich habe mir gedacht, komm, Scheiß drauf, bis Mittagessen da ist, mache ich einfach mal an.
So, und was ich unbedingt brauche ist, an Technik-Kram, ich brauche Quick Charge USB.
Also nicht wirklich was fürs Auto, sowas hier in der Richtung.
Ja, so welche.
Und davon aber am liebsten billige.
Und ich glaube, das ist was, was wir am besten bei AliExpress kaufen.
Mini HDMI.
Woher weißt du, dass das ein Mini HDMI braucht?
Habe ich mir nämlich auch aufgeschrieben.
Raspberry Pi, ja, das ist richtig.
Habe ich mir auch aufgeschrieben.
Die sind alle ein bisschen teuer hier, wie es aussieht.
Guck mal, hier habe ich hier bezahlste 10 Euro für ein Gerät.
Wenn wir da auf AliExpress gucken, Quick Charge USB.
Kann man das jetzt richtig schreiben?
Quick Charge USB, USB.
Da kriegt man ein Fünferpack für 10 Euro oder so.
Was hat das mit Quick Charge USB zu tun?
Moving Fish, elektrisches Spielzeug für Katze USB.
Legit kein Photoshop.
Das kau...
Das kaufe ich garantiert nicht für die Katze.
Da sind mit Sicherheit irgendwelche China Chemie Zeug drin.
Und die Katze beißt rein und ist krank.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Also wenn ich mir so Zeug kaufe, ist das ein.
Aber für meine Katze kaufe ich kein China Kram,
der irgendwie kaputt geht.
Jetzt werde ich von der Arbeit angeschrieben,
ob ich ansprechbar bin.
MTF, ich habe frei.
Finde ich ansprechbar.
Krieger, klar.
Das ist definitiv Made in China.
Allerdings, das Schöne ist halt,
wenn man es in China kauft, ist es viel billiger.
Woher wissen die Chinesen,
dass ich mir gerade Schuhe bestellt habe?
Okay, Quick Charge USB, Quick Charge.
Ich kann nicht schreiben, Leute.
Quick Charge.
Nicht fürs Auto.
Ich will das nicht fürs Auto haben.
Ich will ganz normale, ganz normale Sachen für.
Okay, dann suchen wir mal.
Hier, sowas da in der Richtung.
Aber nee, nee.
Dann suchen wir mal EU.
EU.
Ja, PC Lustig, genau.
Ja, sowas.
Exzellent.
Ja, da kommen wir der Sache doch schon näher.
Moment, was?
Zehn Cent?
Zehn Cent klingt sehr nach Monka Smoke.
Das fliegt in die Luft.
EU, okay, 298.
Aber da sieht man mal, was das für ein Unterschied ist.
Amazon zehn Euro.
Und hier, das ist nicht für den Raspberry.
Also nicht ausschließlich für den Raspberry Pi.
Für alle möglichen Sachen.
Für alle möglichen Sachen ist das.
Und es bietet sich an, mittlerweile Sachen mit Quick Charge zu kaufen.
Was ich nicht ganz verstehe, ist, welcher Port macht was?
Ja, da stimmt schon.
Also viele Chinasachen sehen jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig seriös aus.
Gerade die Produktbeschreibung ist immer ziemlich fail.
Aber ich glaube, die kann man mal ausprobieren.
Was, was macht denn hier welcher?
Welcher Anschluss macht denn hier was?
Oder hat es einfach nur auf Spaß an der Freude unterschiedliche Farben?
Quick Charge 3.0
Warum haben die denn?
Also gar mit einem 3 in 1 Kabel gibt es das.
Das ist, glaube ich, gar nicht so schlecht.
Für einen Euro 30, einen Dollar 30.
Übrigens, das ist absichtlich, dass ich das in Dollar stehen habe.
10 Cent.
Das ist absichtlich, dass ich das auf Dollar stehen habe.
Weil PayPal ist irgendwie der Meinung, mein Konto ist in Dollar.
Stimmt, was kostet das von 10 Cent?
Ok.
Gebaited.
Gibt es überhaupt nicht.
Doch, ich habe genug USB-Kabel.
Allerdings sind diese Dreifachkabel sehr praktisch.
Schauen wir mal.
Also angenommen, ich kaufe jetzt hier.
Das juckt die überhaupt nicht.
Kann ich lieber.
Moment, 50 Stück.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
50 Stück kosten 2 Euro nur.
Moment.
Oh, hier oben.
Hier oben für 10 Cent.
Die schaffen es doch nicht mal, ein echtes Bild abzudrucken.
Ach, hier, das USB-Kabel kostet 10 Cent bestimmt.
Auch nicht.
Das ist einfach gebaited.
Das ist...
Das ist verarscht, die verarschen uns.
10 Cent.
Normalerweise ist es bei AliExpress immer so, dass dann so ein Miniteil irgendwo dabei ist, was dann 10 Cent kostet.
Aber ist hier nicht so.
Keine Ahnung.
Ok.
AliGeBait.
QS.
Sind die Kokona-Stecker?
Schwarz oder weiß?
Ich glaube, ich nehme es in weiß, weil bei mir im Flur überall weiße Tapete bzw. Hellgrün im Flur.
Ich glaube, das sieht besser aus.
Wir können einfach 5 davon, 5 davon machen.
Was?
5 davon?
Mit Einkaufswagen?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Kostet das nur 2 Euro Versand?
Das ist ja poggers.
Ok, wann?
2.7.
Das ist auch vollkommen ok.
Das ist mega günstig.
Guck mal hier.
Huge.
Ok, stellen wir es mal auf Euro um, was es dann unter der Haube kostet im Endeffekt.
Nein, das ist nicht 7.2.
Das ist 2.7.
Das ist Kokona-Datum.
Guck mal, dann gibt es noch das hier.
Das kostet sogar 3 Euro.
Sendeverfolgung, das ist wichtig.
Was?
100 Stück?
Nein, warum soll ich?
Ok, 100 Stück.
Weil der Chat es will.
Also ich meine, wenn ich es richtig sehe, man kriegt für knapp 100 Euro 50 Stück mit Quickcharge.
Das ist massiv billig, aber so viel brauche ich nicht.
Also 10 Stück würden wir schon komplett reichen.
Mal gucken, wie sich das mit den Versandkosten verhält, wenn ich 10 schwarze und 10 weiße
nehme.
Das dann extra kostet.
Ja, das kostet natürlich extra.
Ok, das ist doof.
Ja, da nehme ich nur die weißen.
Exzellent.
Perfekt.
Wobei, das ist echt günstig.
Das ist echt günstig.
Das gefällt mir.
Nice.
Wahnsinn.
Easy.
So, also als nächstes brauchen wir noch mehr.
Wir brauchen noch ein Mikro HDMI auf HDMI brauchen wir noch.
Können wir gleich gucken, vielleicht können wir das auch bei AliExpress mit bestellen.
So was hier.
Das ist bestimmt das gleiche.
Ok, das sind zwei Stück.
Komm mal, exakt das gleiche gibt es bei AliExpress für die Hälfte.
Wozu brauchst du denn 20 Stück?
Future use.
Wie gesagt, ich kaufe ja immer mindestens drei bzw. fünf bei solchen Sachen.
Ich brauche keine 20.
Absolut unsinnig 20 zu kaufen.
Aber deswegen machen wir es einfach.
So, das kostet 9 Euro bei Amazon und 3,35 Euro.
Und das ist exakt das gleiche bei AliExpress.
Dann bestellen wir uns doch gleich bei AliExpress mit.
Zumal es auch keine Versandkosten kostet.
So kleinen Scheiß.
Das ist ja geil oftmals, ne?
Also, ähm, die haben bei so kleinen Kram kostet der Versand aus China nichts.
Das muss man sich mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen.
Der Versand von einer Packung, keine Ahnung, was kauft man sich so in Deutschland?
Was kauft sich denn so der Durchschnittsdeutsche im Internet?
Also, von einem...
Was kauft man?
Was kaufen die sich denn so?
Ich bin ja nicht der Durchschnitt, was beim Kaufen angeht.
Ähm...
Haarwaschmittel.
Also, wenn man sich Haarwaschmittel kauft in Deutschland,
nach Deutschland verschickt, was in Deutschland hergestellt ist,
kostet das so zwischen 2 und 4 Euro Versand.
Mundschutz, Klamotten, ja, was auch immer.
So, das Standard DHL ist, glaub ich, 6,50 oder so was.
Also, sagen wir mal, zwischen 2 und 6 Euro Versand kostet das.
Genau, du bestellst dir Klopapier aus Deutschland, innerhalb von Deutschland versendet,
kostet zwischen 2 und 6 Euro Versandkosten.
Ähm, ich bestell aus China einen Adapter.
Und das ist umsonst.
Das ist schon hart, oder?
Oder alternativ für billiger.
Natürlich haben wir hier einen absolut weltweit bekannten...
Übrigens, DHL-Versand kostet 67 Euro.
Ja, 30 bis 50 Tage.
Das ist normal bei den günstigen AliExpress-Dingern.
Das ist normal.
Schaut mal hier, das ist den anderen, hier gibts den ja nochmal.
Die haben genau das gleiche.
Ich mein, man kann auch sagen, dass man AliExpress Premium Shipping nimmt.
Das Problem ist dann, dann kostet es das gleiche wie in Deutschland.
Also, vollkommen wurscht.
Und außerdem, ähm, wenn ich wirklich mal dringend so ein Kabel brauche,
kann ich es mir immer noch hier kaufen.
Das ist halt der Vorteil von Amazon.de.
Amazon.de ist es morgen da.
Doch, Amazon.de ist es morgen da.
Da ist halt die Frage, ob es einem das wert ist.
In dem Fall würde ich sagen, ist mir sogar wert, das auf Amazon.de zu kaufen.
Weil dann kann ich es mit dem Raspberry Pi 4 gleich ausprobieren.
Dann lassen wir das mal mit AliExpress.
Ähm, das lohnt sich dann nicht.
Gut, ähm, wollen wir mal gucken, was Klopapier bei AliExpress kostet?
Gibt es nicht, okay.
Was kostet denn, was kostet ein Mundschutz?
Mundschutz.
Mundschutz, Maske, Corona, genau, was kostet das bei AliExpress?
279.
So ein billig Ding.
From?
100 Stück.
Easy, guck mal.
Kannst du ja einfach kaufen für 16 Euro, 100 Stück, passt, perfekt.
Und am besten lässt man es sich halt auch aus Frankreich oder irgendwo verschicken, ja.
Das kostet dann noch nicht mal viel.
Guck mal, kostenloser Versand nach Germany.
Innerhalb von einer Woche.
Da kannst du dich doch nicht beschweren, oder?
100 Stück oder 50 Stück?
50, 50, 50 Masken, 8,53 Euro.
Das ist bestimmt günstiger als auf Amazon.
Ja, guck mal.
Auf Amazon ist der Kram unnötig teuer, 16 Euro an der Mobile.
Guck mal, auf Amazon kostet das doppelt, das ist bestimmt exakt das Gleiche.
Das ist bestimmt exakt das Gleiche hier, die zwei.
Musst du gar nicht arbeiten, nee, montags muss ich nie arbeiten.
Exzellent.
Ich überlege mir gerade ernsthaft, ob ich nicht einfach einen 50er Pack tatsächlich mit bestelle.
Wann kommt das nächste Video?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe jede Menge Videothemen, aber ich weiß nicht, wann ich mich dazu aufraffen kann, wieder Videos zu machen.
Komm, wir kaufen das auch noch, easy.
Keine Ahnung, kann ich dir nicht sagen.
Ich habe ein ziemlich gutes Warzone Gameplay.
Wo wir gestern gewonnen haben.
Jeder 10, 11, 12 Kills.
Also jetzt kein Weltrekord Gameplay.
Aber am Ende 40 Kills.
40, 50 Kills.
Zusammen.
Und gewonnen.
Ich glaube, das ist ganz nett, das könnte man echt zeigen.
So.
Leute, legit.
Legit Doktor.
Kein Stockfoto.
Die sind extra ins Krankenhaus gefahren, haben das Bild gemacht.
Gut, jetzt haben wir noch eine Runde.
Jetzt haben wir noch eine Runde.
Masken bestellt.
Perfekt.
Die nehme ich dann mit auf die Arbeit einfach.
Lege ich hin.
Kannst du jeden nehmen, der will.
AliExpress Maske.
Da kriegst du dann auch schön direkt die Coronaviren aus China mit in der Maske.
Exzellent.
Oh, hier noch billig.
Oh, das hat einer im Chat.
Einer im Chat hat Klopapier gefunden bei AliExpress.
Sehr gut.
Perfekt.
Kostet, Versand.
Kommt in einem Monat circa an.
AliExpress Standard Shipping.
Aber das lohnt sich nicht für 10 Euro.
Guck mal, ich hab.
Hier hab ich Klopapier bestellt mal.
Oh, die haben aber schlechte Rezession.
Warum haben die so schlechte Bewertung?
Ey, die Leute beschweren sich jetzt nicht wirklich, dass wenn sie während der Coronazeit
Klopapier bestellt, es etwas länger dauert, oder?
Kracknoobs, Alter.
Das sind so richtige Bobs.
So richtig Internetnoobs, die das schreiben.
Wie viele Lagen?
Vier Lagen?
Oh, meint.
Vier Lagen, drei Schicht?
Was?
Was ist vier Lagen, drei Schicht?
Kann sich da irgendjemand einen Reim drauf machen?
Sind es jetzt vier Lagen oder drei Schichten?
Das ergibt keinen Sinn.
In der Beschreibung steht dreilagig.
Ja.
Wisst ihr, was das cool an AliExpress ist?
Man kommt eigentlich wieder ein Video auf YouTube.
Vielleicht kommt echt bald ein Warsound-Gameplay.
Ich hab ein ziemlich gutes.
Wisst ihr, was das cool an AliExpress ist?
Ich hab nur gute Erfahrungen bisher gemacht mit dem AliExpress.
Nicht Kundensupport, diese Kundengarantie,
Kundenproblemlösungssupport von AliExpress.
Wenn du das kriegst und du schickst an den Support von AliExpress
eine Beschwerde und sagst hier, in der Beschreibung steht vier Lagen,
sind bloß drei Lagen, da kriegst du innerhalb von einem Tag dein Geld zurück.
Das ist so geil.
Bei PayPal haben die einen Monat rumgemacht, bis ich meine Kohle wieder gekriegt hab.
Weil der eine Shop mir was mit zerbrochener Glasscheibe geliefert hat
und sich einen Monat nicht gemeldet hat.
Da hab ich bei PayPal diese Konfliktlösung aufgemacht.
Die haben über einen Monat rumgemacht.
Über einen Monat haben die rumgemacht bei PayPal,
bis ich da mein Geld wieder gekriegt hab.
Bei AliExpress hab ich was bestellt.
Und die haben das auf ist zugestellt gesetzt.
Und ich hab Beschwerdefall aufgemacht.
Ging's irgendwie um 25 Euro oder so.
Beschwerdefall aufgemacht.
Ich hab gesagt, Leute, ihr sagt, ich hab's bekommen.
Ich hab's nicht bekommen.
Dann haben die gesagt, ah ja, sorry, sorry, Tracking Link ist kaputt.
Wir geben ihnen einen neuen Tracking Link.
Hab ich einen neuen Tracking Link gekriegt.
Das war exakt der alte Tracking Link, der auch nicht funktioniert hat.
Und dann hab ich geantwortet, ja Leute, es funktioniert immer noch nicht.
Und dann kam der Shop an und meinte so, ah ja, sorry, tut uns leid,
bitte gib uns noch etwas Zeit.
Da hab ich einen halben Tag nicht drauf reagiert.
Und auf einmal hatte ich mein Geld wieder.
AliExpress-Kundensupporter hat das Ticket geschlossen, hat gesagt,
ja, Kunde hat nicht reagiert.
Und dementsprechend kriegt er das Geld wieder.
Bei Paypal ist es umgedreht.
Kunde hat nicht reagiert, Händler kriegt das Geld.
Bei AliExpress ist es so, Kunde hat nicht reagiert, Kunde kriegt das Geld.
Exzellent.
Man kann sich echt nicht beschweren.
Ich wurde noch nicht einmal gescampt bei AliExpress.
Nein, das Versandtool hab ich nie weiter dran gemacht.
Vielleicht mach ich da irgendwann mal weiter.
Ich verwende es selbst, ich verwende es selbst nicht.
Nicht mehr.
Vielleicht auch, weil ich es nicht fertig gemacht hab.
Blödsinn, kauf ich nicht auf AliExpress.
Genau, weil ich meinen Klopapier hier gekauft hab.
Da wurd ich ja geflamed auf Twitter.
Hier, Leute.
Da wurd ich ja hardcore geflamed.
Hier.
Ah, hier haben sie mich geflamed.
Oh, da wurd ich geflamed.
Ich hab mich hart rangenommen auf Twitter, ey.
Ja, 1. April, das war da, wo es in Deutschland kein Klopapier mehr gab.
Und ich hab mir einfach hier online halt schon 3 Wochen vorher Klopapier bestellt, als es losging.
Wisst ihr, ich hab mir so gedacht, als es losging und es die ersten Berichte gab,
Leute rennen in den Supermarkt, kaufen wie viel Klopapier,
da hab ich mir gedacht, wir machen jetzt einfach Big Brain Move.
Und wir machen bei dem Scheiß einfach nicht mit.
Wir suchen uns einen online Großhändler raus und bestellen dort einfach,
wie viel sind das, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12 Packen.
Wir bestellen uns einfach bei einem Großhändler 12 Packen,
warten 3 Wochen am Klopapier und siehe da, es hat funktioniert.
Und das auch noch am 1. April.
Eigentlich ein richtig gutes Trolldatum, oder?
Ehrenfreund sagt, hallo, hallo Ehrenfreund, exellent.
Du wolltest doch ein YouTube Video zu einem Video in einer Woche Hexenlernen machen.
Äh, was?
Das wollte ich übrigens in G-Bate Video machen.
Hast du das Papier schon aufgebraucht?
Nein, ich hab das Papier noch bis auf 2 oder 3 Packen gar nicht angebrochen,
weil ich mir gedacht hab, jetzt wo es wieder normales Klopapier gibt,
ich hab das einfach bei mir im Schlafzimmer unter dem Tisch liegen.
Und ich heb das jetzt auf, falls noch mal eine zweite Corona-Welle kommt
und die Leute wieder so ausflippen.
Da muss ich diesmal nichts kaufen.
Und sollte die ganze Corona-Geschichte mal vorbei sein,
dann kaufe ich halt einfach mal, keine Ahnung,
ein paar Monate kein Klopapier und brauch das auf.
Guck mal, wie sie sich aufregen, wie sie sich aufgeregt haben alle.
Das ist genau der Grund, warum es eine Knappheit gibt
und mit solchen Posts wird es nicht besser.
Kompletter Schwachsinn, kompletter Schwachsinn,
das hat damit überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Hätten das alle so gemacht wie ich mit Klopapier,
hätte es überhaupt kein Problem gegeben.
Das wäre viel besser planbar gewesen.
Du hättest überhaupt keine Andränge gehabt,
die Leute hätten sich im Laden nicht angesteckt.
Viel besser, viel besser.
Das haben alle so machen müssen wie ich.
Bin ich überzeugt von, haben sie aber nicht.
Kacknubs.
So, Schuhe haben wir bestellt.
AliExpress haben wir auch bestellt.
Ja, Monsterwischen, zum Glück hat die Nase nicht geblutet gestern.
Ich habe nur einen dicken blauen Fleck an der linken Seite.
Auch hier, auch die linken Seite.
Jetzt bräuchte man das XQC.
Haben wir irgendwelche XQC Subs,
die XQC Shnows posten können oder wie das heißt.
Das wird jetzt passen.
Wie teuer ist Klopapier eigentlich beim Lidl oder Rewe?
Weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht, keine Ahnung.
Was ist denn das für eine Stream?
Was ist denn das für eine Stream Deck Verarsche unten links?
Das ist eine Stream Deck.
Das ist keine Stream Deck Verarsche.
Das ist eine echte Stream Deck.
Richtig echtes.
So, also wir müssen was essen.
Das Essen kommt gleich, Leute.
Ich muss mich beeilen.
Musik nicht, bisschen laut.
Passt, gut.
Also, was ich auch noch brauche ist,
ich brauche eine neue Packung Schrumpfschleuche.
Die habe ich, das Problem ist,
das Set ist eigentlich auch ganz nützlich.
Kauf Nanoliefs.
Was sind Nanoliefs?
Ach, das sind diese Karrel,
um es an die Wand zu machen.
Also, das Set ist eigentlich auch ganz nützlich.
Das Problem, was ich mit diesen Schrumpfschleuchen hier habe,
ist, die sind zu kurz.
Die sind zu kurz und ich mache es bisher so,
wenn ich etwas bisschen Längeres brauche,
dann schiebe ich halt zwei Schläuche übereinander.
Aber das ist nicht so schön.
Ich hätte gerne noch ein paar längere.
Und vielleicht auch noch ein paar,
die ein bisschen anderen Durchmesser haben als die.
Hast du einen 3D-Drucker?
Ja, habe ich.
Weil das wahrscheinlich die nächste Frage ist,
deswegen kann ich das gleich beantworten.
Ich habe ein I3-Mega-S-Any-Cubic.
Den hier.
Zu kurz, was hast du damit vor?
Ja, zum Beispiel,
irgendwelche Sachen, die nicht isoliert sind,
Schrumpfschlauch drum machen oder so.
Der ist und Ehrenfreund, was sagst du?
Also ich finde den echt gut.
Ich muss sagen, die ganze 3D-Drucker-Geschichte
hat sich bei mir echt gelohnt.
Ich kenne mich ja.
Normalerweise, also ich kaufe mir oft solche Sachen
und danach benutze ich sie halt nur ein paar Mal.
Aber nachdem ich mir den 3D-Drucker diesmal nicht gekauft habe,
einfach zur Spielerei 3D-Drucken,
Hieprunz, das ist eine gute Idee.
Muss ich gleich mal kurz rollen.
Das ist eine richtig gute Idee.
Das werde ich machen.
Wo haben wir ihn hier?
Anycubic.
Aber nachdem ich mir den 3D-Drucker diesmal nicht gekauft habe,
für irgendwelche sinnlosen 3D-Drucker-Spielereien,
sondern wirklich einen Anwendungszweck für hatte,
nämlich für mein ganzes IOT-Projektzeug,
für mein Automatisierungszeug und Mikrocontroller-Zeug,
zum Beispiel Gehäuse drucken,
hat sich das wirklich gelohnt bei mir.
Ich verwende ihn nicht oft.
Ich habe ihn von Anfang an nicht oft verwendet.
Aber wenn ich ihn verwende,
dann ist es, was rauskommt, auch wirklich praktisch.
Ich habe euch ja mal das Foto gezeigt
von dem 3D-gedruckten Wi-Fi-Gehäuse.
Post-Image.
Image.
Wo auch immer ich das habe.
Na gut, ist auch egal.
Hast du IOT-Broker laufen?
Nein, ich habe nicht IOT-Broker laufen.
Ich habe Home Assistant laufen.
So.
Aber das mit dem Auf-Rolle finde ich richtig gut.
Das ist die beste Idee ever hier.
Chat, huge, big brain.
Und alles, das liegt nur daran,
der Chat ist einzig und allein in der Lage,
so gute Ideen zu haben,
weil durch den Subscriber-Account
der IQ mittlerweile so unglaublich hoch ist,
dass jeder im Chat
quasi schon der Kopf fast explodiert.
So, was für ein Durchmesser hat denn das Ding hier?
Also Chat ist wirklich hier kurz davor,
den hier zu machen.
So.
Also das ist wirklich hier kurz davor,
den hier zu machen.
Ich muss sagen,
das lohnt sich wirklich,
öfter streamen.
Erstens gewöhnt man sich voll dran,
dass man einfach Stream an,
das ist schon fast ein normales Stream anzumachen.
Ich habe in letzter Zeit
wirklich relativ oft gestreamt.
Und ich muss sagen, ich habe jetzt gerade
ein bisschen gestreamt.
Ich muss gerade mal
ins Creator-Dashboard gucken.
Ich glaube, ich habe jetzt schon wieder
so viele Abonnenten wie an Weihnachten.
Und an Weihnachten hat man denke ich
immer am meisten in der Zeit,
da sind die Leute spendabel.
Also das ist wirklich
richtig nice.
Ich finde das gut,
letztendlich lohnt sich für alle.
Man kann regelmäßig zuschauen,
sofern einem das gefällt.
Was ich immer noch nicht verstehe, warum es einem gefällt,
aber es ist scheinbar genug Leuten zu gefallen.
Ja, lohnt sich für alle, das ist doch richtig nice.
Kannst du es mal dein Home Assistant Setup zeigen?
Nein, kann ich nicht,
weil da ist sehr viel Leak dabei.
Von GPS-Daten bis iPhone-Gedöns,
Name und alles Mögliche.
Stream, Stream ist das beste, beste Bezeichnung.
Wer sagt denn Stream?
Stream.
Secrets-Yaml.
Ja, Secrets-Yaml, aber
GPS-Daten und Zeug auf Map und allem
ist trotzdem im Web-Interface zu sehen.
Und auch iPhone, GPS
und auch Name und sowas.
Ich habe ja verschiedene User,
die so heißen wie die Leute.
Also, ne, kann ich leider nicht zeigen.
Nein, einen Artillery-Side-Winder-X1
sagt mir gar nichts, Ehrenfreund,
habe ich noch nie gehört.
So, also das ist wirklich Big-Brain-Idee,
muss man sagen,
dass man Schrumpfschläuche auf einer Rolle kauft.
Was ist ein guter Durchmesser?
3,2 Millimeter, taugt das.
Was haben wir sonst noch zu bieten?
So ein paar Fette habe ich,
so ein paar Fette habe ich für Outdoor-Projekte.
Was man wunderbar machen kann,
wenn man so einen fetten Schlauch hat hier.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das den ist.
Wenn man so einen Schlauch
mit einem richtig fetten Durchmesser hat,
da passt sogar ein Raspberry Pi Zero rein.
Und schon hat man ein Raspberry Pi Zero einfach
Wind, Wasser, Wetter festgemacht
in so einem Schlauch.
Dafür ist es echt praktisch.
Natürlich kann man sich dann auch
ein IP67-Gehäuse holen
und das reinmachen.
Das geht natürlich auch.
Aber hier kann man einfach Löcher reinmachen.
So, was gibt es denn hier?
Aber das ist eine richtig gute Idee
mit dem Schrumpfschlauch von der Rolle.
Hier gibt es die Schrumpfschläuche
in verschiedenen Farben.
Das ist wirklich nur 1,99?
Ist aber günstig, oder?
Warum ist das so günstig?
Das sieht auch richtig viel aus.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Ach, Moment!
Man kriegt nicht diese Rolle.
Man kriegt eine Rolle mit einer Farbe, oder?
Ah, ja, okay.
Und wie lang?
Wie lang?
Also, wie viel ist es?
Es steht gar nicht dabei.
Anglerharten?
Okay, da wäre ich jetzt nicht drauf gekommen.
Also, wofür ich sowas verwende,
ist sowas hier zum Beispiel.
Post.
Warum findet der denn jetzt?
Kann das sein, dass ich das in der anderen V-M
gezeigt habe, die Bilder davon?
Ich glaube, ich habe die hier
in der V-M gezeigt.
Post, ah, hier.
Ja, genau, für sowas hier zum Beispiel.
Guck, da sieht man, das ist zu kurz.
Da ist ein Schlauch zu kurz.
Meterware bedeutet ein Meter, okay.
Ja, sprich, das ist ein bisschen kurz ein Schlauch gewesen.
Ich meine, ich müsste das jetzt nicht
komplett isolieren, allerdings...
Nee, Kabel kürzen ist auch keine
allzu gute Idee an der Stelle.
Weil ich muss ja...
Der Anschluss, also das kommt ja dann hier raus.
Der Anschluss muss hier rein.
Nein, ich kann die Kabel nicht kürzer machen.
Und der eigentliche Controller,
der muss hier hinten rein.
Es funktioniert nicht.
Also, die Kabel müssen schon
ungefähr so lang sein.
So, und natürlich will ich jetzt nicht,
wenn dieses Ding hier da rumhängt,
dass man da mal einfach ohne,
mit irgendwas anderem an die Kontakte
dran kommt.
Das ist natürlich jetzt nicht so sinnvoll.
Deswegen wollte ich hier einfach
so einen kleinen Schrumpfschlauch drüber ziehen
und gut ist.
Aber reicht nicht.
Dafür hätte ich schon gerne ein bisschen längere gehabt.
Das hat nicht richtig gut funktioniert,
miteinander stecken.
Na ja, dafür, dafür brauche ich das.
Genau.
Jetzt kann ich euch vielleicht auch mal das...
Was haben wir da sonst noch für Bilder?
Post, Image.
Ich hatte doch irgendwo eins.
Switchtab, Album.
Nee, okay, keine Ahnung.
Ich hatte irgendwo ein Bild
von dem einen 3D-getruckten Gehäuse.
Das ist richtig nice geworden.
Wahrscheinlich ist er auch auf Twitter.
Weiß nicht mehr.
Kann sein, dass ich sogar auf Twitter hatte.
Egal.
Und deswegen brauche ich ein bisschen längere Schrumpfschläuche.
Also, finde ich richtig gut.
Wie viel ist das hier?
3,2 Millimeter ist vielleicht...
Kosten die kleinere Variante nicht wirklich mehr.
Wie viel ist das?
11 Meter.
Oh, das ist cool.
Das finde ich nice.
Das hat was.
Go-Cable-Ties.
Was?
Warum steht da Go-Cable-Ties drin,
wenn da überhaupt kein Cable-Tie drin ist?
11 Meter, da habe ich ja Jahre.
Also, wenn ich mal gucke,
was ist hier das Kleinste in diesem Set,
was ich habe?
45 Millimeter?
Nee, nicht 45 Millimeter.
Es stimmt nicht, 4,5 Millimeter.
45 Millimeter,
das wäre ein riesen fettes Teil, Alter.
Hä?
Ach nee, 45 Millimeter ist die Länge.
Das ist 1 Millimeter mal 45 Millimeter.
Ah, jetzt verstehe ich das.
Okay, von 1 Millimeter bis 13 Millimeter habe ich hier drinnen.
Ja.
Dann kaufe ich mir vielleicht ein kleines und ein mittleres.
Aber das war, also wer auch immer die Idee hat,
das war richtig Big Brain.
Ich glaube, das mache ich.
Also, das war wirklich exzellent.
Ich kaufe mir einfach zwei Stück davon.
11 Meter, da habe ich die nächsten Jahre genug.
Perfekt.
Nachmittag heute Abend wieder streamen, weiß ich nicht.
Hatte ich heute eigentlich nicht vor.
Ich streame jetzt eh nur, bis Essen kommt.
Und Essen müsste innerhalb nächsten 20 Minuten da sein.
So, also was gibt es als nächstes zu kaufen?
Ja, der Hybrons, richtig Big Brain.
Ich weiß nicht, ob er noch da ist.
Ist er noch da? Hybrons, bist du noch da?
Das war nämlich exzellent Idee.
Wenn du noch da bist, schreib mal was.
Dann gibt es einen Sub.
Die Idee finde ich nämlich so gut,
dass ich da mal einen Sub für spendiere.
Da kannst du sagen, du hast 4 Emotes verwendet.
Ah, du bist schon Sub.
Oh.
Ja, nee, dann.
Ja, Dankeschön für den Sub,
den du mir irgendwann mal dagelassen hast.
Nee, da kann ich dir keinen Sub spendieren.
Geht nicht.
PP Hands.
Nö, gut.
Was brauche ich als nächstes noch?
Ja, ich wollte mal gucken. Ich will mir keinen kaufen.
Ich sage es gleich schon. Ich will mir keinen kaufen.
Aber ich wollte mal gucken, was der aktuelle Raspberry Pi 4
mit 8G kostet.
Wohlgemerkt, ich will mir keinen kaufen.
Weil ich den Anwendungszweck
nicht
sehe da drin.
Ach, gibt es nicht. Ausverkauft. Warum ist der ausverkauft?
Warum?
Das ist komplett
sinnlos.
Mir fallen nur ganz beschränkt
Sachen ein, wofür das sinnvoll wäre.
Minecraft Server, genau.
Minecraft Server ist eines der wenigen Sachen,
wo es mir wirklich,
wo es Sinn ergibt.
Ach so, das ist doch Starterkit.
Das brauchen wir gar nicht.
Shop now.
Nee, ist auch ausverkauft.
Kostet er bei Amazon.
Pi 4 8
sind auch als 8G.
Unsinnig,
teuer wegen der SD-Karte,
Alter. Was bei Reichelt gibt es denn?
Ich habe, glaube ich,
doch, ich habe bei Reichelt schon mal was.
Eine Sache habe ich schon ein paar,
ich habe bei Reichelt
und bei Konrad parallel bestellt
während der Corona-Zeit.
Und ich glaube, dass
Konrad viel, viel
schneller war mit dem Liefern.
Fast eine Woche.
Als die die Geschäfte zu hatten.
Da habe ich, was habe ich denn da bestellt?
Die Sachen für meine Klingel.
Ein 10er-Pack Optokoppler,
ein 10er-Pack irgendwelche Widerstände
und ein 10er-Pack Magnetsensor-Dinger.
Pi 4 8G.
Kurze Frage, wie kann ich bei i3
meinen Bildschirm sperren?
Mit i3 gar nicht direkt,
aber was du machen kannst ist,
du kannst sowas wie S-Log verwenden zum Beispiel.
Was jetzt hier nicht installiert ist,
aber S-Log ist eigentlich ganz angenehm.
Ja, ich installiere mal kurz S-Log.
S-Log kann nichts außer Bildschirm sperren.
S-Log.
Bäm, Bildschirm gesperrt.
So sieht der Bildschirm gesperrt aus.
So, und dann tippst du einfach dein Passwort ein.
Und wenn du dich vertippst,
wird es rot.
Und wenn du es richtig getippt hast,
wird der Bildschirm entsperrt.
S-Log, das ist der
Suckless-Log-Manager
oder so.
Liegt. Oje, fuck, Passwort liegt,
aller.
Aber S-Log, das ist
der simpelste Screen-Logger, den ich kenne.
Der kann nichts, also der kann kein Bildschirm
schonen oder sonst was, kann ich dir gleich sagen.
Der kann nichts, aber du kannst
den auch im Hintergrund laufen lassen.
Ich habe nämlich auf der Arbeit
irgendwie im Hintergrund laufen.
Ich weiß aber nicht mehr, wie ich das gemacht habe.
Also, ich habe
es auf der Arbeit auf meinem Notebook so eingerichtet,
dass es sich nach 5 Minuten
keine Tasteneingabe selbst
erfährt.
Natürlich, ich meine, bei meiner VM
habe ich sowas nicht,
weil, wozu? Was ich beruflich
mache, da habe ich tatsächlich ein ganz gutes
Video zu.
Ich glaube, wir haben
sogar auch ein Ausrufezeichen Beruf, kannst
da auch mal machen. Aber wenn du
es ausführlich wissen willst,
kannst du dir das Video hier angucken
auf YouTube.
Da habe ich mich
knapp eine Viertelstunde zu
ausgelassen, was ich auf der Arbeit mache.
Komm mal, wir haben
sogar eine, wir haben sogar eine
Erklärung dazu.
Das ist Baro hier.
Was der alles macht.
Exzellent.
Hat er Patrick gemacht. Okay.
Dann, was der Patrick alles macht.
Die Beschreibung,
Alter. Die Beschreibung.
Er kümmert sich um Software
Repository Skit, ist
Release Manager für neue Versionen und kontrolliert
alle Pullgequests, um denen auf den Sack zu gehen.
Die müssen kommenten. Ein Clip,
mit dem er es ausführlich erklärt.
Exzellent.
Das ist die beste Beschreibung ever
davon, was ich mache.
Wie sieht es mit der Server Tour aus?
Es hat sich da nicht allzu viel geändert, außer,
dass die 4HE-Kiste nicht mehr in Betrieb ist.
Und,
also,
so sah es ja vor ein paar Jahren bei mir
im Serverraum aus.
Und die Kiste hier oben ist ja nicht mehr in Betrieb.
Dafür habe ich jetzt eine kleinere stehen,
mit deutlich leistungsschwächiger Hardware, die aber reicht.
Die steht allerdings neben mir und nicht im Serverraum.
Ich habe das immer noch nicht ordentlich gemacht.
Ach, die Server Tour auf der Arbeit.
Ja.
So sieht es da aus.
Ok, Leute. Ich muss...
Wow. Vm, please. Was ist los?
Ok, ich muss noch mal kurz ein paar Kleinigkeiten
einkaufen. Hast du Fachinformatiker gelernt?
Ja. 2007.
Also, Schrumpfleucht... Genau.
Was kostet jetzt ein Pi 4? Wollte ich doch gucken.
Pi 4 mit
8G.
80 Euro.
Ok, und der 4er?
Das lohnt sich doch nicht.
Das Upgrade lohnt sich nicht.
Wie gesagt, mir fällt nur ein Minecraft Server.
Das ist echt das Einzige.
Das wäre echt das Einzige,
was mir einfällt.
Minecraft Server.
Ich glaube, wenn ich auf
einem Raspberry Pi 4
einen Minecraft Server betreiben würde,
der auch frequentiert wird,
dann würde ich mir vielleicht
wirklich die 8GB-Variante kaufen.
Allerdings würde ich auf jeden Fall
Booten von SSD und
auch noch ein bisschen Swap auf SSD machen.
Aber ansonsten, mir fällt wirklich nicht viel ein,
wo man 8GB
auf einem Raspberry Pi 4 braucht.
So ziemlich alles andere
ist CPU-limitiert.
Wenn du zum Beispiel nass machen willst
mit Verschlüsselung,
ist das gerade auf dem Pi,
der die Krypto-Extensions nicht
mitlizenziert hat,
komplett CPU-Bound,
weniger IOU-Bound,
lustigerweise, sondern komplett
CPU-Bound. Du meinst,
du musst IOU machen
mit der CPU, du musst Encryption-Decryption
machen mit der CPU, du musst
Samba machen mit der CPU,
vorbei. Kriegste nicht.
Kriegste kein Gigabit voll. Kriegste vielleicht 40 MB
die Sekunde drüber. Was den meisten
daheim vielleicht reicht, aber für
meinen Nass ein bisschen zu lahm ist.
Ich meine, ich habe nicht umsonst 10 Gigabit Netzwerk
daheim, um da
den Raspberry Pi als Nass dran zu hängen.
So, also was
brauche ich jetzt noch?
Ich brauche 9,
den habe ich letztens
geschrottet. Ich brauche einen kleinen
mit so einen kleinen
Seitenschneider, allerdings nicht die fetten.
Da habe ich einen richtig guten
von Knipex, die man
eigentlich Kniepex ausspricht, aber jeder sagt
Knipex.
Allerdings brauche ich einen kleinen.
Den habe ich, genau, das ist der großen, den ich habe.
Das Ding ist wirklich, das Ding ist top.
Damit schneidest du Finger
durch, wenn es sein muss. Okay, ne, Finger ist jetzt
kein gutes Beispiel, Finger sind weich.
Damit schneidest du Zäune durch.
Alles, ey, das Ding ist
echt geil. Aber ich brauche
so ein bisschen kleineren.
Ich brauche ein bisschen kleineren.
So ein, nicht so ein
hier, sondern so ein
so ein kleines Knips-Ding.
Ich weiß nicht, wie die heißen.
Elektro, aaaah.
Elektronik-Seiten.
So was kleines brauche ich, genau.
Ja, so was hier, genau so.
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen dem
und dem?
Außer, dass der
mehr kostet.
Der ist
schwarz und der ist weiß.
Das ist ja in der heutigen Zeit schon
allein kriege ich gleich schon die Abmahnung
für die Aussage, aber das ist halt in dem Fall
bei dem Seitenschneider so.
Was, wo ist der?
Ah, der hat so eine
Überzug, so eine Schicht.
Am Dienstag
ist 10 Jahre Inscope21 auf YouTube.
Bei dir dauert es auch nicht mal lang.
Richtig, bei mir dauert es
bis Oktober
glaube ich noch.
Guck mal, mein erstes Video ist von
das ist nicht ganz
das erste
26. Oktober,
ja.
Dann war das erste Video, keine Ahnung,
20. Oktober oder so.
Was bedeutet denn brüniert?
Ist das irgendwie, dass es nicht rostet
oder so? Für was, was darf ich mir darunter
vorstellen? Das ist natürlich excellent,
ne? Die Vorschau ist größer
als die Detailansicht.
Äh, das
Ding hab ich.
Genau die Abisolierzahl hab ich glaube ich auch.
Die ist echt nice.
Seitenschneider Set, ne brauch ich nicht, den hab ich auch schon.
Korrisionsschutz.
Der wird eigentlich nie nass, aber ich meine
die zwei Euro kann man ausgeben, ne?
Oder? Warum nicht? Die zwei Euro kann man
ausgeben.
Kauf bei AliExpress, ne.
Das kaufe ich nicht bei AliExpress.
Aber genau so einen brauch ich.
Excellent.
So einen kleinen.
Wenn man Kabel dranlötet und Kabel
kürzen muss und sowas, da ist der hier
komplett overkill.
Da brauchst du eine halbe Stunde bis du den großen
in der Hand hast hier.
Um ein kleines Kabel abzuknipsen.
Die hier sind besser.
Mit denen kannst du aber jetzt halt nichts
fettes durchschneiden.
Okay.
Das ist gut, den kaufen wir.
Ne.
Ne. Den kaufen wir.
Bei AliExpress bekomme ich 20
für den Preis. Ja, aber die sind crap.
Werkzeug kaufe ich nicht bei AliExpress.
So.
Sehr gut.
Haben wir noch einen Seitenschneider in Ordnung?
Elektronik, super.
Knips.
Elektronik, super Knips.
Mit mehr Komponenten Hülle.
Das ist ja auch eine wahnsinnige Mischung aus
Deutsch und Englisch.
Man kauft gar nichts bei AliExpress.
Doch.
Man kauft zum Beispiel
USB-Ladegeräte mit Quick Charge.
Und
Monka Corona
Masken kauft man bei AliExpress.
Ich will damit auch nichts
größeres durchknipsen.
Wie gesagt, ich will damit nur so Kleinkram
durchknipsen, wie ich hier eben gezeigt habe.
So Kleinkram will ich damit durchknipsen.
Wenn ich Sachen zusammenlöte oder so.
Hier.
So Kleinkram will ich damit durchknipsen.
Und das ist halt viel angenehmer
mit so einem kleinen
als mit so einem ganz fetten Seitenschneider.
PC-Netzteile kaufe ich nicht bei AliExpress.
Der Link ist
top.
Das ist halt billigster
China-Crap.
Also hier kriegste wahrscheinlich schon
Ausschlag, wenn du das Plastik in die Hand nimmst.
Nein, die sind gut.
Weiß ich nicht, ob die gut sind.
Ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher, ob die
ob die richtig gerade sind.
Ich glaube, die gehen gar nicht mal richtig
gerade aufeinander, oder?
Ja, beim i3 Mega war eine dabei
und die war richtig mies.
Nee, also, ganz ehrlich
so ein Teil, das kaufste dir
und das kannst du 30 Jahre lang verwenden.
Das kann ich theoretisch verwenden,
bis ich den Löffel abgebe, wahrscheinlich.
Ich meine, ich bin eh mal schon 35.
Ich lebe ja auch nur noch vielleicht 50 Jahre.
Da kann ich dann irgendwann mal
meinen Enkeln, die ich wahrscheinlich
nicht mehr verwenden kann,
irgendwann mal den Leuten erzählen,
Leute, den Seitenschneider,
den hat euch der Opa bei Amazon
bestellt, 2020.
Könnt ihr euch vorstellen, 2020.
2020, bei Corona.
So.
Was brauche ich denn sonst noch?
Ah, ganz wichtig, ganz wichtig.
Was ich wirklich unbedingt wieder
brauche, ist
sowas.
Unbedingt brauche ich da wieder welche von.
Weiß aber nicht, ob ich die am Band nehme
oder
oder ob ich die
als schon vor
geschnitten.
Das Zeug ist,
also ohne Scheiß, Leute, die Dinger sind echt
extrem praktisch.
Also was man damit zum Beispiel super
machen kann, ist Geräte
befestigen.
Also zum Beispiel
nehmen wir mal eure Fritzbox oder so,
weil ich weiß nicht, ob es mit der Fritzbox so gut geht,
ob die glatt unten ist.
Nee, die halten nichts, weil die halten richtig gut.
Gerade die hier, die halten richtig gut.
Wenn du die billige Tesa Power Strips nimmst
oder so, ist das, aber die Dinger halten
richtig gut.
Ich hab das schon seit drei Jahren, habe ich hier den Kram
an der Wand hängen mit, juckt es überhaupt nicht.
Was man damit gut machen kann, ist zum
Beispiel, wenn man
sagen wir, ihr wollt eure Fritzbox
an die
Schrankwand hängen oder so.
Ja, mal angenommen, man möchte nicht
schrauben, sondern möchte kleben, was ja
sein kann. Stellt euch vor, ihr habt eine Schrankwand,
ja, und eure Frau, Freundin,
Mutter, was auch immer sagt, oh nee, die
Fritzbox im Wohnzimmer, das geht überhaupt
nicht, dass man da Technikgeräte sieht.
Kommt ja oft genug vor.
Dann sagt ihr einfach, Moment,
pappt ihr das Ding an die Fritzbox dran
und pappt das Ding
auf die andere Seite an die Holzwand ran
und flutsch.
Also nicht nur einen an die
Fritzbox, man sollte zumindest
schon mal links einen und rechts einen dran machen
an die Fritzbox und dann klebt ihr die eine Seite
an den Schrank, die andere Seite an die Fritzbox
und dann habt ihr einen schönen Klettverschluss
oder ja, so eine Art
Klettverschluss dazwischen.
Also es
gibt bestimmt viele billige Sachen,
aber die sind
echt gut.
Wie gesagt, ich hab seit drei
Jahren den Kram hier an der Wand hängen.
Das berührt sich nichts.
Linus Tech Tips hat
immer Velcro
promoted.
Vivo Still spricht
uns allen aus der Seele.
Oder wobei
ist sie fraglich.
Es kommt drauf an, in welche
Gemütslage man sich gerade befindet.
Ob das eher Pepehands ist
oder eher Pogchamp.
Linus Tech Tips
hat immer hier Velcro
Zeug
promoted, aber diese
3M Sachen finde ich persönlich
besser.
Ja, ich glaube davon
kaufe ich mir wieder ein paar. Wo ich jetzt noch nicht ganz sicher bin,
kaufe ich mir vielleicht mal eine Rolle,
weil die gehen mir doch schon relativ schnell
aus.
Und die übrigens, warum
ich öfters neue brauche, ist
nicht, weil die kaputt gehen oder so,
sondern weil ich immer mal gerne meine Geräte
umpositioniere. Und das kannst du halt
vergessen. Die kannst du nicht
ab und wieder dran machen. Wenn du die abmachst, ist
kaputt.
Oh, Essen kommt Leute. Essen kommt.
Essen kommt.
So, haben wir
bestellt. So, ich muss jetzt mal kurz
gucken, ob ich alles habe.
Ich muss nicht an die Tür gehen.
Ja, eine Sache wollte ich noch nachgucken.
Das können wir jetzt noch schnell machen. Ich wollte
gucken, ob die mittlerweile auf Amazon
auch in Deutschland
SATA-Multiplexer
Karten haben, die
SATA 3
können. Aber ich glaube denen nicht, dass sie SATA 3
können. Das ist Jebait.
Ich hatte mir nämlich schon mal
einen gekauft, wo explizit SATA 3
dran stand und 6G
und es war keine 6G-Karte.
Übrigens empfehle ich nicht, die Dinger zu verwenden.
Kann ich gleich dazu sagen. Also
wer die Möglichkeit hat, mehrere
Platten einfach direkt an SATA-Anschlüsse
anzuschließen, sollte das auf jeden Fall machen.
Stimmt, wir können nachgucken,
was das für ein Chip ist.
JMB3
JMB3 7
Ne
Tja
Das sind die neuen.
Das ist ok.
Ein gutes Bild von
Ich erkenne es nicht.
JMB3 2 1
Kann das sein?
3 2 1
JMB3 2 1
Was ist das?
Guck, Serial 2 Port
Das ist Jebait.
Das ist kein SATA 3
Das ist ein SATA 2 Port.
Oder? Ne.
Moment.
Nicht Jebait.
Ja, was denn jetzt?
Ah, Moment. Das ist ein SATA 2
Interface, allerdings
Ne, Moment. Ne, 3G. Das ist ein altes.
Das ist kein 6G.
Ja, die wissen nicht, was sie schreiben.
Hier, SATA 2 Interface
3G
Ne, Jebait. Richtig Jebait.
Das ist nur ein SATA 2
und nur 3G. Das suckt.
Das kann man nicht gebrauchen.
Ja, Müll.
Siehste, ich hab mich da schon mal Jebaiten lassen
mit angeblich SATA 3 0 und sie sind nicht SATA 3 0.
Ja, ich weiß, dass SATA 2 nur 3G ist.
Aber sie schreiben, es ist SATA 3
und der Chip da drauf ist aber nur SATA 2.
Das ist Jebait.
Kompletter Crap.
Ja, Müll.
Müll.
So.
Also hier. Crap.
Nur SATA 2.
Was steht im Titel?
Das ist was anderes.
SATA 3.
Hier steht SATA 3.
Also ich hab mir schon mal so einen bestellt hier
und da war nur SATA 2. Deswegen ist das
Jebait.
Er kennt nur eine Festplatte.
Ja gut, wenn ein Board das nicht unterstützt,
dann muss das Mainboard das unterstützen.
Das ist safe Jebait, Patrick.
Denke ich auch.
Ja, das ist Jebait.
Und ich wurde schon mal
Jebaiten lassen.
Ich hab mich von denen schon mal Jebaiten lassen.
Ich hab schon mal eine bestellt.
Jebait.
SATA Multi...
Multi...
Multiplier. Nicht Multiplexer multiplier heißt der richtig.
Da müssen wir die doch bei AliExpress
bestellen.
Die 3G Variante.
Ja.
Weil die sind auch legit
3G von AliExpress, ich hab mich bisher immer
gedrückt die von AliExpress zu bestellen.
Wobei das ist genau der gleiche Kram.
Aber es gibt 3G bei Aliexpress, das weiß ich.
Könnt ihr mal da ordentliche Photos von machen, dass man was erkennt?
Was ist das für ein Bild?
Hat er das aufgenommen im Samsung-Telefon von 2005 oder was?
Okay, die sagen sogar, dass nur das Alte unterstützt wird.
Kaffeekarte bei Aliexpress, das ist ein Neues.
Bei Aliexpress ist das Schöne, wenn ich da einfach melde hier, kann ich liefern zu Germany,
warum nicht?
Aus Spanien vielleicht?
Aus Australien?
Aus Vereinigten Staaten?
Aus China?
Warum kann ich nicht aus Frankreich nach Deutschland liefern lassen?
Warum?
Es ist natürlich viel einfacher, was aus China liefern zu lassen als aus Frankreich,
das ist schon klar.
Sollte jedem einleuchten, ne?
Konnte man nicht mal Artikel-Standort irgendwo auswählen bei Aliexpress?
Man konnte bei Aliexpress doch mal Artikel-Standort irgendwo auswählen oder war das Banggood?
Das könnte auch Banggood gewesen sein.
Oh, Bowser-Musik.
Na gut, was auch immer, Leute, das war nur ein ganz kurzer Stream heute, weil jetzt ist
Mittagessen da.
Muss ich off.
Jetzt wird's Essen kalt.
Vielleicht sehen wir uns nachher, aber ich glaube eher morgen.
Mal gucken, schauen wir mal.
Vielleicht mache ich heute Abend doch.
Vielleicht mache ich heute Abend noch einen Stream.
Müssen wir mal schauen.
Poggers ist busy.
Wir sehen uns, bis dann, macht's gut, CU, ich geh jetzt was essen.